citizens of the reject Nation it is time
for what if season 2 episode 5 Coy how
are we feeling oh holy crap what if we
make it we make it we might do them all
we might we might get to Christmas
ladies and gentlemen it's past Christmas
when this episode's coming out so what
you can do right now is tell us what do
you think about this episode is it a
good one does this satisfy your what if
scenario bar yet tell us what you hated
about it be nitpicky yeah that makes the
internet happy argue with someone just
get the thumbs up on your opinion down
there in the comments by vitol leave a
like on this video ladies and gentlemen
also subscribe click the notification
Bell because we are powering through all
of them and I've been really enjoying
the season th far thank to all of you
thanks is the word for joining us at our
patreon page full Reaction watch where
you seek up with your own copy of what
if that's available over there we cover
several things with highlights and watch
alongs included but seriously thank you
all for helping us have a glorious year
at our patreon Co you ready I'm so ready
let's do it let's find out what this
one's about we don't see the titles in
no idea what it is just
[Music]
fine chatari I know I've seen this one
I've seen this movie Let's Come Oh
Captain Carter's back thanks G what are
new friends for girls get it done yeah
ay Squad
little trick I picked up in Berlin uhhuh
nice oh is this a sequel I think it's
seal to season 1's Carter where did that
move come from oh that you know Moscow
had a strange childhood Lake Bell is so
good at Black Widow just in general as a
person too being like Bell that was a
violent Ant-Man wasp cool oh good call
th keep fighting down here Widow let's
go for a
ride Hal well you so hot
anytime she's the captain of my heart
her we could just punch him a whole lot
dos have a very punchable
face okay worried I'm a little worried
guys but we give a chance we're SL you
into our thought process while the
opening credits are going racial Vice
from Black Widow I wonder how that
relate all right black widows in this
episode we'll see it's the most an
opening has worried me yeah the opening
just had that what of season one vibed
it did and the further you get away from
what if season the better for me like
that's like an egregious season just we
don't talk about that one that's why we
were worried this whole time but now I'm
enjoying it I don't do
sequels what's the point of revisiting
the story when there are infinite
stories to be told weird for the MCU to
be telling me this yeah about that
revisiting she thought her story was
over but it was only just beginning so
it's a sequel to the last episode of
what if season one she's getting the win
Soldier Story yes on your left Fury has
a mission for us man you need more
Hobbies it is the Winter Soldier it
literally is I can promise you that this
won't be the strangest thing I dealt
with
today oh Steve oh he's going to be the
winner soldier the Hydra stomper Hydra
stomp oh yeah I guess he the antagonist
there's someone
inside are I'm guessing going to make
him the villain cuz he's a white
[Laughter]
man I'm Steve Rogers more like RoboCop
I'm the same my you love uh
oh what if Iron Giant was a bad
guy I do like that it's shot like winter
soldier sweet
sauce
maybe it's just that like resurrected
mind problem you know when you're like
who am I I have amnesia like Jason
Bourne yeah yeah I'll
Attack I think it's going to be the
Winter
Soldier Steve's hair he's got beard oh
he's got a beard he's Winter
Soldier they brainwashed
him you got to go to the market and get
plums
I do like the Winter Soldier outfit with
the Captain Britain flag on it Rogers
and Barnes formed their own two-man Army
and destroyed every Hydra base until the
last mission claimed Steve's life rumors
about the hydro stomper survival since
the 1960s why wasn't I debriefed on this
because we didn't debrief you on Bigfoot
either if the stories are true then the
hydro stomper is responsible for some of
the world's worst acts of Terror rewind
back what about Bigfoot yeah is he real
like bucking it was rumored that her old
home found and housed the Hydra stomper
Rachel we uh Steve evil you didn't tell
me didn't see the point in breaking your
heart twice okay so season one was a lot
of what if we remake a movie as an
episode this is worrying this is where
we smash things together the stomper the
world's most dangerous killer I have a
shield a shield ain't going to stop it I
mean she's got super strength surely you
understand that the sovian aid package
is generous considering considering it
doesn't cover has Barnes you got a age
oh that's cool won't have a country torn
apart by Civil War because we didn't do
the right thing that's greaty would sir
we believe there might be an attempt on
your life I may be an old man boys but
I've punched Nazis and shed beers with
aliens someone read my catheter get down
get
down oh that's cool mirroring the end
see I feel like that Shield would do
would do damage I mean it saved like 30
people just now that thing is an
international terrorist attempting to
assassinate a Us official trusting you
to do the right thing this feels more
like Nick Fury than he doesn't the
Marvel's or secret Invasion the second
half secret evasion thieves in the suits
alive well that's a different Kell ofon
something Howard cooked up after the war
good that means I can break
it it is interesting because it's a love
story you know and she wants to save him
yeah but so so was Bucky and Steve yeah
but that's more like we best butts this
this is good I'm having fun with this
one I think it's better than the first
episode of season one yeah and I think
it's an inventive way to make Winter
Soldier work
again it's hard because it just feels
like hitting the same story beats cuz it
is we'll see well sick I'm giving it a
shot
coin
it's fun seeing Evil
Steve I'm sad to see himam go down I'm
hoping he's like
Nomad a come on cool locked in on the
target weapons High we do permission to
shoot n what
secretary no Steve would be stupid
enough to do the same for me Steve hey
oh my God kill him Steve this should be
great old man Bucky this ain't
you let's get a drink kill him like the
old days what do you say buddy kill him
you and me oh I think they might
actually that closeup makes me think
they're going to kill him okay I was
wrong nope it's fake out there it
go oh we got
[Music]
both that's a great cool honestly a lot
of the animation action Sav so much much
better and again Winter Soldier badass
brutal hand to hand the bar was
high oh the reverse of through the walls
is through the ceiling oh yeah yeah I
like
that it actually feels like someone drew
this time yes versus a computer made it
all AI is bad Marvel lesson learned I'm
glad they got their AI to make it look
hand yeah better
AI
save him do the thing to die faster put
your hands behind your back it works
with science it's real
St Steve wake
up oh
no hey Peg I got you catch him as
opposed to jumping out of the plane
catch him with a
plane why don't you just reverse the
plane tap the brakes reverse the play
Slow the plane
down we're in come on come on come on
come on come on come
on Good Luck
Carter thank you sucker for a good love
story
huh welcome to St Kilda Scotland why'
you spill the
beans fo's here I got the reference why
just F your beans the only thing keeping
him alive you can't remove it n unless
you want to put him straight into a
coffin you got to go to someone from the
Red Room his suit's rebooting now we'll
see who's at the controls when he wakes
up I do like that it's obviously still
skinny Steve but they're making the
gauntness tie into the machine keeping
him alive what if we no well if not
Stark then Banner no unplugging it and
plugging it back in is not going to work
did you try that tends to work we'll go
to the Red Room what I've never been a
woman to quit a fight the Red Room did
this Rachel W before I join Shield
tracking down and killing the head of
the Red Room are you certain you killed
him mhm dabbed him in the coted artery
with a cork screw so yeah I think I
did but at the end of the day it meant
nothing I like the pairing of them a lot
really fun yeah no one can find it not
even
Shield sorry I can take you also cap
this a similar relationship of
hierarchy it's been a while Peggy I owe
you that date Steve should have said
dance not too far from the Red Room a
sovian military base training camp for
KGB spies when the Kremlin abandoned it
the Red Room moved in it started off
Rocky but I'm enjoying it man we see I'm
I'm half in I'm pretty in I'm more in
than not that's not fair I'm like 70% in
I'm just hoping it lands with enough
Hood Spa to rationalize the First Act
being Winter Soldier again a great day
in the neighborhood but I'm
INRI oh this is
cool it's like an those nuclear towns
those testing sites yeah which is where
you'd want to build a plutonium man I
love America I feel like I'm in a horror
movie I we wants fought a giant space
squid I signal the Red Room it's
bait it turned pretty
easy okay uh I'm going to go find a
lemonade stand or something he just he a
dink against his
metal it's the real Iron stomper what do
you think of the future in a word faster
cars computers even the news moves fast
and uh the men do they move faster oh
yeah a it's a
baby so creepy I spent years going after
Hydra as long as I was on a mission I
could pretend you weren't G it's crazy
no not crazy very human M
finally Peggy widow bites packs sting
o oh creepy it's a baby
cool cool cool cool I'm so down yes the
Red Room using this
propaganda oh that's
rad pile
through this looks
incredible Sho there wow wow
you for got to mention these robots
aren't very nice sorry my memory is a
little fuzzy it's like Iron Man 2o
yeah Russia thought America was like
this we didn't get cable TV over here
just shows up without a
shield let me just show up go this is
what would happen pretty Qui what you
think Black
Widow
whoa that is
unsettling it's unnerving cuz it has
that ironic family touch that americ the
Red Room oh I'm sorry
Natasha but we turned your bedroom into
a gam oh she in charge there she is
mission accomplished ma'am no regret no
boss only me and his mission there might
have been some truth to their connection
all right you can say I told you so
later I don't want to fight in front of
my mom mom is let's unpack that later
shall we this was all a trap to find me
okay now I might say it I don't know
whether to kiss you kill you or dissect
you maybe all three yes good plan all my
widows have seen your movie that was a
movie it was a musical Ah that's clever
Easter
egg oh let's see it o is she going to be
I mean the the shoes have been something
get
her damn it
Steve I got my two pistols there's no
problem that's plenty it's fine I can
roll
booyaah some great tracking shots man DP
work
combining Winter Soldier and black widow
like this I'm in it's got me it works
works really well cool reverse Avenger
shot Dave this isn't
you wake
up oh that's fun I like that
use wow so
sick the action in this is so
good how could Natasha have survived
this I think she got
clear it's me Steve it's
Peggy you owe me a date mess with his
head psychological mind
[Music]
Warfare not the cookies everyone needs
those especially Santa
cool yeah I like the Sinister plays a
lot
here there you go you're working the
Shadows
crunchie yeah beat his brain
back
she cool oh excellent that was excellent
dope damn oh that was a top ped oh wow
this is a beautiful sequence this Haun
so stunning
hard aim for her left knee she damaged
in bicycle accident in third
grade this I love how just a
training
session all right let's see her power
set
ooh starting to feel like Batman the
Animated Series yeah it's like the the
visual expression of The Haunting
Flames
great I can't get over how much better
it
looks and how the action feels so much
more weighted I am done fighting Steve
I've been fighting for so long to end
the war I'd like to see some like marks
on her though even if this is the end I
want
you but he can't get out of the
suit oh
no no no yeah man you just got back wait
no
a
ouch
Batman
yep there it goes that where that I was
like where' that handle
go o wow some serious
composition oh wow that was a pretty
shot Matt Matt are you all right no we
need to run of course we
do start off worried man but I really
like this the First Act I was not I was
really worried it'd be a rehashing and
instead they comined this isn't the end
of her story whenever they go past just
the sounds silly the what the what if
part yeah and they just embrace the
story they're telling it it always turns
out great this season I see all I
observe all I know what the hell is this
hey
Natasha oh the interconnected
one a good
question yep we're teasing the
interconnected episode will more than
likely get right in the finale I'm
assuming show us strange Supreme is it
strange Supreme that is she what
1602 more she will s our world so much
for taking a night off watch you watch
you
1602 is going to be awesome if the big
finale 1602 I'm going to lose my
might just be the next that was awesome
a that was cool you know what's really
cool though what's cool that shirt
you're wearing Coy yeah it is it's a
great way to show you're a real reject
supporter a real one a real real reject
supporter and also like we got the space
babies of the Galaxy one we've got who
influences the influencers we've got
Child Protection Services
we got a whole bunch of te's and it is
absolutely my personal favorite way just
saying to support the channel and you
look good while doing it I mean come on
you know those are comfortable and they
F Well very comfy breathes well it's got
some fluidity to it and it looks great
bounce the
pecs hold on there you go yeah look
Hydra get get closer little Frank
gorillo action little Crossbones for you
now we're going to get flagged for
inappropriate content because of because
of my pegy Carters nice pecky Carters
you did it you did it I need
water we've been doing this for hours I
really haven't drank any water today I'm
like must be what I'm I need water um
yeah uh okay okay I'm there with you
concern top opening Pro I was like oh
God this feels like like all the
problems of what if season one just like
cheesy Fest and like hey what if we just
swapped out some people and then it's
not like a what if it's like a let's
just remake it yes and I was I had the
same concern as you you got ahead of it
a little faster than me you you you were
more in about five minutes before me and
then I hit a point where I was like oh
no he's right because it I started to
see the the through line of where they
were going with it of like oh we're
going to combine elements of the Black
Widow storyline and the and the and the
captain Carter storyline but you know
the thing is with with all these
episodes of what if every single one of
them feels like they could use an extra
five to 10 minutes I agree they should
not have done this tight 30 they would
have all benefited by like a nice 35
especially our Le I think both of us
agree episode two is the weakest um
because For Me episode two lands the
softest this landed really well this
landed great like it got better as it
kept going and the weight of the fight
scenes in particular are fantastic I
love the setting I just love how much
emotion can be evoked solely due to what
they're drawing you know and like the to
throw them into the ironic haunting
setting of the nuclear test site which
has imagery that evokes where the the
time period they they actually originate
from I think is great how and how that
ties into Red Room it ties into both the
movies it's like that perfect ven
diagram of the Russian propaganda and
the Americana yes yeah like the the
horrors of their past converging
aesthetically not just character-wise
but and and and how they told like
really you know they they make all the
comments all the time about like Bucky
and Steve is really a love story and
they actually just told the Love Story
version here which I thought was
excellent uh I don't feel personally
like I liked this Agent Carter I thought
as an episode it's a really great like
it got to a great point and like again
so much of the time unlike season 1 so
much of the time there can be moments
that I think are absolutely undoubtedly
saved by just wow look how great this
actually looks 100% you guys got to keep
in mind too we are fortunate enough to
be watching this on a screener um you
know because uh we're part of the press
list for him and we're fortunate to
watching the screener and that is not as
great a quality yeah we're watching this
downgraded yeah yeah as what you guys
get to watch or watching on like Disney
plus servers or something and and I'm
still like this looks amazing also you
may notice how bright it is in here
we're watching this under fluoresence
like if you're watching this in the dark
in high quality it must look even better
because right now we're like a little
blinded and watching it like on a you
know screener so this is this Show's
gorgeous yeah it's absolutely gorgeous
and and I and so much of that and again
when you're doing
animation more than a a liveaction with
CGI or whatever animation has to has to
elicit an emotion it has to it just has
to and I think this show is actually
doing it yeah and so I could watch these
moments of fight scenes that are just
not just like oh look how cool and
pretty that is it has weight it has
character it it moves the story it a lot
of times with like a liveaction movie
you might be like oh I need to watch
like the I need to be invest in the
characters in order to care about the
visuals the visuals can get you
emotionally invested that's what I'm
talking about with the inverse here
agree and I think that is the strength
of what if season 2 in particular now
has any episode so far risen to the
heights of this doctor strange episode
not for me personally in terms of a
story I think as a consistency though
and as an overall season it a far out
does season one already yeah there's no
finale feel I mean obviously we're not
to the finale yet but there's nothing
that feels as strong as episode 8 season
1 I agree but four was four right or
four five the strange Supreme one oh and
then it wrapped up in eight yeah yeah
yeah talking about four I'm talking
about the just the doctor strange
episode yeah like that was like a
perfect like 30 minute episode yeah it
was it was pretty incredible but but for
me this is Leaps and Bounds above the
average feel oh yeah yeah like that I
would rather have the problem with
season one is that's one phenomenal
episode out of like eight fine like
seven of them are like fine and here I'm
like no there's there's a lot of
greatness and
almost I don't remember much about two
but but one three four like there's
there's been pretty much something great
yeah in every single one of them and
it's so funny cuz 88 was the one I was
looking forward to most that was like
that like premise wise but I think that
also shows how good the episodes have
been that the premise hasn't been what's
got me it's been the delivery on the
premise as it's presented yeah exactly
cuz this one like you said the premise I
was like I'm a little concerned and then
as soon as it like actually let me
breathe I was like man this is stunning
I'm invested I love the convergence of
themes and ideas
and the delivery is incredible my my
only concern is I still and I want to I
still don't feel as much for Agent
Carter exactly Captain Carter is I want
to because if you like have you have you
interviewed or met um Haley Atwell no no
I second you do melt everything Cap's
ever done makes sense like if you're in
the the same breathing space as Haley
Atwell suddenly you're like I would
fight for 100 years and go back in time
and and abandon everything I would
absolutely kill off Rebecca Ferguson to
have Haley ell and convert her to
Scientology as needed you do what you
got to do do what you got to do to keep
her and that is what I don't feel from
the animated version and that's
unfortunate that's the only thing I wish
I could like connect to yeah you know
and in what I'm I'm gonna bring it back
to your point in a second because what's
what was missing for me here when I said
I wish there were some marks on Peggy
what after she was fighting with Steve
when she's saying I'm tired I'm like
okay yeah you're you're saying you're
tired we need to see it you know when in
Winter Soldier when he's fighting with
Bucky at the end and and he's just I
could do this all day whatever and he's
he's refusing to like give up on Bucky
yeah he's he's Captain America but he's
still looks like messed up yeah and if
they did that with Peggy then that would
have just hit so much harder and it's
her accent on top of it that Feels So
Posh and Polished it's like she's fine
all the time like there's also that
verbal element of like yeah you're good
it seems like yeah you're you're
quitting because you're emotionally
tired but I feel like you can also be
visually tired yeah like we need need to
like physically mess you up a little I
want to care about Captain Carter I do
yeah cuz I like the chemistry between
her and black widow and I I I think this
show is absolutely at its best whenever
they get past winking at the audience
and that's what I mean by when they get
past SE and Jeff Goblin Winks at a self
with but like they could have easily
done with like uh with Rachel vice's
character Melania Melina Melinda Melinda
something like that Melania Trump
Melania yeah yeah um check her grave oh
no that's the other one his other wife
they could have just been like oh she's
look at us we're what if and she's the
villain no they just they just they just
do it she's just a villain yeah and I
think whenever they get past winking is
when the show is excelling cuz in a
universe you wouldn't know the other
viers to wink so when they do it it like
takes you out of the suspension of
disbelief of like wait wait we're in
another universe that's not special here
it's just the way things are so when
they make it special I'm like you guys
don't get the premise and season one did
a lot of winking it was alln it was
nothing but like except swapped it four
and eight weren't winging and that's why
we're were referring to them as as the
good ones especially four if I if I
rewatch what if in a year or two or if I
ever do a a massive Marvel rewatch I'll
probably watch episodes four eight and
then this as my what if yeah no I I
don't I I've never rewatched I've only
rewatched the doctor Str that's I watch
the finale because I do assume that'll
tie in to Secret Wars in some way but
that's it yeah yeah 48 this cuz this has
all been great and rewatchable and
Christmas is now got I think this has
been awesome this has really been
awesome overall and even like yeah I I I
think a lot of this was really
uh I can't wait to see I yeah I'm
curious how it lands at at their ninth
episode can't wait to see can't wait to
see more all right koyi let's see more
let's see more by ending this video
first let's do that and I'm going to get
some water you should you seem you you
you you look vexed you look how Peggy
Carter should after figh tired you look
a little disoriented I was like I'm Tire
I'm usually tired but I'm more tired
than usual dehydrated and I'm like oh
yeah I'm probably really dehydrate his
eyes are wavering
yeah all right guys let's go to the
bathroom
everybody go to the
[Music]
bathroom